[Music]
so in happy ending news submitted by
happiest cactus a guy gives an x-rated
speech at a local council meeting asking
for the legalization of happy ending
massages actually saw this
yeah but we got to watch it together
it's [ __ ] I have a question for you
guys after we want because this is this
is some this is different it's so
exciting I have a question after we're
done watching he looks like somebody
that would already ready so I proposed
this the city allows for licensed sewers
to give genital massages oh the masseur
and the client both agreed to it we let
someone get naked and have every other
part of their body touched and rubbed by
a massage therapist no we let
proctologist spend their day finger in
men and sticking things up their penis
so if someone wants to yank a guy's
crank I say letter picture this a big
old sweaty [ __ ] back
get him off with your hand actually be
that much worse than giving him a
full-body massage
getting up in there under the folds of
fat or being the proctologist sticking
your finger up his ass and that brings
me to this is about people imposing
their morality on the rest of society if
a grown adult wants a [ __ ] another
grown adult and another grown adult is
willing to get one for money then that's
both freedom and cop
ilysm and that's the foundation of our
country another problem with a genital
massage then don't get one and allow
other consenting adults to do what they
want that would truly be a happy ending
for everyone so here's my question okay
do you think that's [ __ ] serious or
do you think that's a troll because
either way I love it a hundred percent
that was serious and that was the most
creepiest thing I've ever seen in my
life if anybody wanted to propose that
he is not the guy to do it you know what
I mean a better ambassador like it makes
sense who would be the best somebody
that can make eye contact with a human
being that's not wearing a turquoise
shirt under a green flannel like your
name creepy guys are the best guys to
get because if they're getting happy
into massages they're not going out
doing creepy [ __ ] this guy is such a
honorable pervert that he's like this is
illegal and I really want a [ __ ] but
I can't get one so I'm gonna go and do
this the right way like a concerned
citizen he looks like he smells like
warm mayonnaise that's what he looked
like he smells like I could smell him to
the screen and [ __ ] oh God did ya like
like warm craft nail
I don't know but part of me he's too
young like I feel like he's doing it as
a troll as like the biggest [ __ ] troll
like you know to show his friends look
at what I did I got troll vibes from
yeah really yeah some of the words that
he's using you know like yank yank and I
knew he was too kind of like I'm a
comedian I'm clever with my words the
way he was like hesitating before each
like [ __ ] nervous I mean was nervous
to say certain words in the public place
and I think he was trying to add a
little bit of humor to lighten it up but
I think he's serious and I think it's
tight because I
really trying to say is like hey there's
a lot of people out there like me so
either we can get happy endings or I'm
gonna go shoot up a school that's what I
feel like you spent a while yeah I'm
gonna get was telling the truth soon cuz
he has that like school shooter vibe
like that look I find the description is
highly offensive that he has a [ __ ]
bull cut he's not Asian
it's [ __ ] trying to [ __ ] steal
our love
if the law passes do you know how many
[ __ ] like [ __ ] places will allow
this kinda like leash all over town dude
it's gonna be all bad they're gonna give
this guy a lifetime supply of tan
jakhary
dude people are doing it already I mean
is Emma sighs okay I like what they were
saying about weed right like we're doing
it already they're gonna be more relaxed
now they made that legal everywhere yeah
yeah I don't understand why that's
illegal
what handjobs yeah because it's not as
risky as like intercourse [ __ ] or
anything it's just [ __ ] hands cuz
were based on crazy religion that's how
it was founded it falls under the sex
[ __ ] and you can't attack somebody's
body they just want that's the second
line so I would say you can go like this
right you going down here you could go
like this is it the is it the minute you
cross the face of the penis like if the
penis is like right here you could
pretty much touch right here or is it
the people or the pubic hair starts I
think it's the speed that you go in yeah
and then like all of that please into it
too also the force cuz there's
somebody's coming up your penis just
doing this no you should [ __ ] me yeah
that's what that means
that's the [ __ ] troll confusing
this just might as well just touch
everything I think guys should get happy
ending I think girls should also get
happy and easy alone [ __ ] rope affection
all right but girls need emotional happy
endings what are we dude you're so
offended wow you're so offended really
wow I didn't know a simple Clint rub
comic can get so [ __ ] crazy I guess
their version of a [ __ ] at a massage
place how come you never got one um here
what was it I think she said is in
Westminster
oh dude tight wow yeah so but she didn't
feel violent she was just at one of
those places unknowingly but dude ass
have you been here before and she said
yeah for whatever reason okay she's not
a dude I guess if there was Clint rough
places and you told me you want to get
your cool would you all do it you don't
go for it yeah why don't you do it now
or what how come you didn't do it when
you're younger like when you're single
and stuff I didn't do it younger because
I wasn't this comfortable before like I
always felt well after you popped out of
here like anything could go in there now
part of Holly
[Laughter]
[ __ ] action anything I'm gonna
addresses I don't like any type of
insertion happening so yes it would be
specifically the clip number two like a
DJ you you want it it is not tore up
it's actually very pretty
alright if you don't believe that
bookies shoulders everybody believe it's
gonna be common thing I don't believe
you I don't believe so
so you're looking for a 1990s Filipino
DJ 1990 no probably not
those are some old series but that she
wets when scratching was the best yeah
now she's now it's just all electronic
yeah you know what it would you do it I
don't think of it in a sexual way let's
say you go to Massage Envy right you're
gonna get the sports whatever a
relaxation massage anyways
head to toe they do the ten ball
whatever do the whole thing don't you
feel like you would that's like that
just finished the entire it is but she
can't you can't tell her not to think of
it in a second it is a sexual thing it
is so you have to think of it in a
sexual way take that part off but
anyways just to like finish I have to
get into that mindset reach the organs
but not always
eventually comment and everyone's like
kind of I got we spot everyone walks
around naked is just everyone is in it
and then I'm like alright not aware of
this I'll try that cuz I know that I got
it done to me I can make it not sexual
and I could just relax they do
everything and then when they're giving
me a hand up I'm not being my [ __ ] his
hand but that's not the definition of it
beyond that's not yeah
you're still getting sexual sexual
pleasure because the if you got a boner
and it feels good that sexual pleasure
OS how sexual because we have to release
yeah and that's not a sexual thing it is
though
no like Oh West II Listed nocturnal
emissions wet dreams
that's sexual it's not it is though
because if you don't have a dream
sometimes that happens with no dream
it's not sexual is just the need for the
relief so if they're helping but that
need for the release is based on the
sexual drive is is you're saying two
things that are scientifically connected
yeah no yeah no that's I brought like
you we have a five sexual you know we
have a need to release that because of
anything sexual is because it's backed
up it needs to come out if we have a
sexual drive because we have a need to
reproduce the exam beans are sexual in
hand no that's not we have a sexual
drive because we need to produce that's
why we have a sexual drive that's why
when we get older our sexual drive goes
away because our testosterone goes down
yes I'm saying scientifically it is a
sexual cuz I get your point of like
sometimes like dudes just need a nut you
know yeah like sometimes I can't think
straight it's like if I done it right
now I could figure out this math
equation cuz I almost I'm almost 100%
sure like Einstein jacked off all the
time oh he was like that smart
just like had no coming in balls it was
just like I got this
you know the nannies at home used to
jack off the little boys before they
went to sleep or country you're up baby
all right hmm I I heard that it was both
boys and girls
oh I don't know about the girls parts
yeah I think when I found out when I was
a kid that girls get horny that [ __ ]
blew my mind why cuz you know he's like
you always thought that guys are the
only ones that get harder the dogs and
then you have to like coax the girl
always well girls were lying oh [ __ ] not
me oh isn't that smart I was like yeah
these girls are that horny it's like why
are you lying cuz cuz you go to church
that's why you lyin
[Music]
[Music]